one of las vegas oldest casinos turns
116.
the historic golden gate in downtown has
survived a lot through the decades now
the ongoing pandemic hector mejia joins
us live at fremont street and main
street with a little bit of history
behind the hotel hector hi
hey there so the golden gate has managed
to stay out of time when other
properties get demolished and replaced
and take a look even the hotel's history
is written in its address one fremont
street
built in 1906 the golden gate still an
existing piece of history casino mogul
derrick stevens is the hotel's ceo the
very first building in the history of
vegas
the very first address in the history of
las vegas one fremont street the golden
gate opened with only 10 rooms hard to
believe it was the largest hotel in las
vegas back then when you think about the
10 rooms the original 10 rooms
a lot of people may not know
the original 10 rooms or 10 rooms that
we've refurbished
exactly like they were
in 1906. it now has 129 rooms over the
decades the property has survived
prohibition and other vegas milestones
and currently living through one the
pandemic think about how many employees
have worked at the golden gate how many
people have come to las vegas and broken
in at the golden gate
bartenders cocktailers
the property has gone through eight
major renovations and derrick stevens
also said without the golden gate its
sister property right next door circa
wouldn't be here today reporting in
downtown hector mejia live local now a
fun tidbit of history just 10 rooms wow
hector thank you